Allen is not the real Santa Claus-- the guy in the North Pole. Obviously-- and I say this to any little kids who might be listening to me right now-- that guy in the North Pole is amazing. Allen is not that guy.
艾伦并不是真正的圣诞老人——也就是住在北极的那个人。显然——我得对可能正在收听节目的小朋友们说——北极的那位是真的很棒，但艾伦不是他。
Allen's just a guy who dresses up as Santa sometimes. Allen doesn't have Santa's flying reindeer. Allen doesn't have legions of elves backing him up. And most of all, Allen doesn't have his years of experience.
艾伦只是一个偶尔打扮成圣诞老人模样的人。他没有圣诞老人的飞行驯鹿，没有成群结队的精灵协助，最重要的是，他没有圣诞老人那多年的经验。
This is my first year as Santa, my first-- oh, I'm going the wrong way.
这是我第一年当圣诞老人，我第一次……哦，我走错路了。
He's driving to his very first chair gig.
他正开车去参加他的第一份“坐镇”工作。
OK. I'm so nervous. I-- [BREATHES] I'm nervous. I'm really, really nervous.
好吧，我太紧张了。我……[深呼吸]我很紧张。我真的、真的很紧张。
A chair gig-- you sit in a chair, talk to kids about what they want for Christmas. One of our producers, Aviva DeKornfeld, rode with him to this job. This was in Redlands, California, an hour or so east of Los Angeles.
所谓“坐镇”工作，就是坐在椅子上，听孩子们说说他们想要的圣诞礼物。我们的制作人之一，阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld），陪他一起去执行这项工作。地点是在加利福尼亚州的雷德兰兹，距离洛杉矶大约一小时车程。
Allen is an earnest guy with a kind face, who-- and he would tell you this himself-- tends to overthink things a little. Really, he told Aviva, he's not sure what to expect at this gig. Like, what could go wrong? So he's just been trying to prepare for everything by making some lists, checking them twice.
艾伦是个真诚的人，面相和蔼，而且——他自己也会这么说——他倾向于把事情想得太复杂。他告诉阿维瓦，他确实不知道该期待什么。比如，会出什么岔子？所以他一直在列清单，并反复检查，试图为一切做好准备。
Last night, I made checklists on my phone for all the things that I would need and all the things I would potentially need. I have a backup for almost everything that I wear.
昨天晚上，我在手机上列了清单，记下了我需要的所有东西，以及所有我可能需要的东西。我穿的几乎每一件东西都有备份。
How come?
为什么？
Well, in case a baby spits up, I need another shirt. If the coat gets dirty. I need another coat. And I have to have extra gloves, and I've been kind of manic about trying to anticipate all the catastrophes that could happen, one way or another, and prepare for them.
嗯，万一孩子吐在身上，我需要换一件衬衫。如果外套脏了，我需要另一件外套。我还得有额外的手套。为了预见可能发生的各种灾难，我简直有点疯狂了，总想着要未雨绸缪。
He's also worried about his beard. He's 53, so his natural beard is still mostly brown.
他也担心他的胡子。他53岁了，所以他自然的胡子大部分还是棕色的。
So I started bleaching my beard in June, and my beard started getting smaller. The bleach was damaging it.
所以我从六月就开始漂白胡子，结果胡子开始变少了。漂白剂损伤了它。
So it was breaking off?
所以它断掉了？
Yeah.
对。
He's tried some expensive hair products to stop the damage, but it's still a little shorter than he wants. And maybe his greatest anxiety going into this gig was the questions that the kids might ask him. Would he say the right thing?
他试过一些昂贵的护发产品来修复损伤，但胡子还是比他想要的短了一些。而且，他这次工作最大的焦虑可能在于孩子们会问他什么问题。他能说出合适的话吗？
There might be a child with a real problem, like their mom is gone, or somebody is incarcerated, or something like that. And I can't-- I can't bring anyone back that they've lost, and I really worry about being asked about that. I can't bring someone home who's on a deployment somewhere.
可能会有孩子遇到真正的问题，比如他们的妈妈不在了，或者有人入狱了之类的。我无法……我无法让他们失去的人回来，我真的很担心被问到这些。我也无法让那些去前线服役的人回家。
He frets and drives on his way to the gig, two full Santa's costumes in the bag. You know, Christmas comes around every year, always the same-- with the same songs, and the same stage props, and same specials on TV. You can get numb to it.
他带着两套完整的圣诞老人服装，一路焦虑地开向目的地。你知道，圣诞节每年都会到来，总是千篇一律——同样的歌曲、同样的舞台道具、电视上播放同样的特别节目。人对这些很容易变得麻木。
It's so easy to lose the magical feeling that so many people had as kids around the holiday. But one thing you can say about Allen-- he's not feeling numb. Just the opposite. He is on high alert.
人们在童年时期感受到的那种节日魔力，长大后很容易丢失。但关于艾伦，有一点可以肯定——他并没有感到麻木。恰恰相反，他处于高度戒备状态。
Not just because he wants to be a perfect Santa for these little kids. Mainly, he's that way because it is his first time in the chair. And there are all kinds of reasons that is a big deal for him, that we're going to get into in a minute or two.
这不仅是因为他想在孩子们面前做一个完美的圣诞老人，主要是因为这是他第一次坐在那把椅子上。这对他来说意义重大，原因有很多，我们稍后会详细聊聊。
But my point right now is, when you're trying something for the first time, you can just taste all the potential and excitement of what it could be. You feel feelings. Which is why this Christmas, here at our show, we thought it would be nice to spend an hour with people who are not doing what they've ever done in the past at Christmas, who are not doing the same old, same old.
但我想说的是，当你第一次尝试某件事时，你能品味到它所有的潜力和可能性。你会产生各种感受。这就是为什么在这个圣诞节，我们的节目想花一个小时，和那些在圣诞节尝试新鲜事、拒绝陈词滥调的人在一起。
We want to spend the hour with people who are trying something brand new at Christmas, because they have a shot at some deep Christmas-y feeling. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
我们想和那些在圣诞节尝试全新事物的人共度这段时间，因为他们有机会获得某种深刻的圣诞感。这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》（This American Life），我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, Does Santa Believe in Himself? OK, so Allen-- or maybe I should say Santa Allen-- is on his way to his first chair gig, as we said. Producer Aviva DeKornfeld went with him to see how he would do on that gig.
第一幕，圣诞老人相信他自己吗？好吧，如我们所说，艾伦——或者我该叫他圣诞老人艾伦——正在前往他第一份“坐镇”工作的路上。制作人阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德陪他一起去，看看他表现如何。
But to understand why he is so nervous and what he hoped to get out of the gig, you kind of have to understand what the job means for him in the first place. And so that is where Aviva is going to start.
但要理解他为什么如此紧张，以及他希望从这份工作中获得什么，你得先了解这份工作对他来说意味着什么。这就是阿维瓦要开始讲述的地方。
Before getting into the Santa business, Allen had a job that was sort of the opposite of being Santa. He was a corrections officer at a state prison. He'd gotten into the work because he needed the money and stability, and stayed for over two decades.
在进入圣诞老人这一行之前，艾伦从事的工作简直与圣诞老人截然相反。他在一所州立监狱当惩教官。他做这份工作是因为他需要钱和稳定，一干就是二十多年。
But he hated it, and felt increasingly queasy about the whole system and his role in it. And then, in 2017, he got a break from it, though not under great conditions. He got really sick and ended up having to take nearly a year and a half off from work for medical leave.
但他讨厌这份工作，对整个制度以及自己在其中的角色感到越来越恶心。后来在2017年，他终于得以脱身，尽管环境并不理想。他病得很重，最终不得不请了近一年半的病假。
He got depressed, stopped shaving, grew a long beard. One day, to cheer himself up, Allen and his wife, Erin, decided to go to a comic book convention.
他陷入了抑郁，不再刮胡子，留起了长长的胡子。有一天，为了让自己振作起来，艾伦和妻子艾琳决定去参加一个动漫展。
Because, obviously, I'm kind of a nerd and I enjoy that sort of thing. But I went there, and I wasn't really having a very good time. And you know, I was taking a break from walking around in the convention, and I'm sitting in a little cafe.
因为显而易见，我有点宅，喜欢那种东西。但去了之后，我感觉并不好。你知道，我在会场溜达了一圈后休息，坐在一个小咖啡馆里。
And I'm having something to drink or eating a sandwich. I don't really remember. But there's this guy there and he says, hey, I like your beard. And I want, oh, um, thanks. And he gave me this little card, and what it is, it's a recruitment card for this Fraternal Order of Real-Bearded Santas.
我在喝点东西或者是吃三明治，记不太清了。有个家伙走过来对我说：“嘿，我喜欢你的胡子。”我说：“哦，嗯，谢谢。”然后他给了我这张小卡片，是“真胡子圣诞老人兄弟会”的招募卡。
Huh. There's something very sort of tied to the real world about the idea of recruiting a Santa, when it feels like it should just be like, some snow falls on your shoulder or something and you become Santa.
哈，招募圣诞老人的想法听起来太现实了，毕竟这事儿听起来应该像是什么……比如雪花落到你的肩膀上，你就成了圣诞老人那样。
Yeah. But no, this was just a guy sitting around at a Comic-Con.
确实，但这只是一个在漫展上闲逛的家伙给我的。
I talked to over a dozen first-time Santas in reporting the story. Nearly everyone had this in common. It was someone else who first identified them as Santa. Turns out, that is the magical snow that falls on your shoulder.
我在采访这个故事时，采访了十多位第一次当圣诞老人的新手。几乎每个人都有这个共同点：是别人先认定他们是圣诞老人的。事实证明，那确实就是落在你肩上的那抹魔法雪花。
Allen shows a business card to his wife, Erin, who suggests he dress up for their godson's kids. Christmas is still months away, but it might give him something to look forward to.
艾伦把名片给妻子艾琳看，她建议他为教子的孩子们打扮一番。虽然离圣诞节还有几个月，但这也许能给他一些期待。
I'm thinking, OK, well, I do have this beard now. And I've always been definitely on the rotund side of things. So I've got that working for me.
我想，好吧，既然我现在有这胡子了。而且我一直偏胖，所以这点条件还不错。
And I went, well, I should quit feeling sorry for myself and maybe do something with this now.
所以我决定，不该再顾影自怜了，或许现在该用这胡子做点什么。
Allen figures, he'll play Santa, just this once, as a nice thing to do for his family. Since he's like a grandfather to these kids, Allen was worried they might recognize him. He bleached his beard white and asked a friend who knows how to sew to make him a red suit.
艾伦心想，就当这次是为家人做件好事，扮一次圣诞老人。因为他就像这些孩子的祖父一样，艾伦担心他们会认出他。他把胡子漂成了白色，还请一位会缝纫的朋友给他做了一套红色的套装。
But on Christmas Eve, as he's heading over to the house, he realizes he actually has no idea what to do. So he just tries to imagine what a real Santa might do, then opens the door and makes an entrance.
但在平安夜前往那家人的路上，他意识到自己其实根本不知道该做什么。所以他试着想象真正的圣诞老人会怎么做，然后推开门登场。
Ho, ho, ho! Who builds a house without a chimney?
吼、吼、吼！是谁没装烟囱就建了房子？
And they're freaking out.
他们都惊呆了。
Is it Christmas Eve?
今天是平安夜吗？
They have no idea it's me. It was the furthest thing from their mind.
他们根本不知道是我，这完全出乎他们的意料。
Let's do this anyway!
不管怎样，让我们开始吧！
I didn't have tremendous expectations going into it. And then, when I did it, it was just this tremendous rush of emotions, and that's not a thing that happens to me a lot. I've been a pretty buttoned-up person most of my life.
去之前我并没有抱太大的期望。但当我真的做了之后，那种情绪的喷涌而出，是我生活中不常有的。我大半辈子都是个非常内敛的人。
So when it was Santa for them, it became Santa for me. It's just one of the most powerful things I've ever felt in my life.
所以，当我成了他们的圣诞老人时，我也成了我自己的圣诞老人。这是我一生中感受到的最强大的事情之一。
When I'm him, I'm a completely different person. And all my little neuroses and doubts and faults and foibles-- it's all gone. And all the problems that Allen has-- Santa doesn't have any of those.
当我是他时，我完全变成了另一个人。我所有的神经质、怀疑、缺点和怪癖都消失了。艾伦所有的烦恼——圣诞老人一个也没有。
Allen loved this new version of himself. But pretty soon, Christmas was over, and so was medical leave, which meant Allen's beard had to go. Because as a corrections officer, he had to be able to wear a gas mask in case a riot broke out at the prison, and you can't properly fit a gas mask over a beard. Allen couldn't afford to quit, so he grabbed his clippers and made himself shave off his beard.
艾伦爱上了这个全新的自己。但很快，圣诞节结束了，病假也结束了，这意味着艾伦必须刮掉胡子。因为作为一名惩教官，他必须在监狱发生骚乱时戴上防毒面具，而防毒面具在胡子上是戴不严实的。艾伦负担不起辞职的后果，所以他抓起推子，把自己剃成了光脸。
[SIGHS] This is going to sound really weird. I still have that beard in a Ziploc bag.
[叹气] 这听起来真的很奇怪，但我还把那把胡子保存在密封袋里。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. I mourned that beard.
是啊，我为那把胡子哀悼过。
Why do you still have it?
你为什么还留着它？
[SIGHS] I probably shouldn't. But it meant a lot to me. It was the key to the door that opened that let me do this. And when I had to shave that beard off, I was pretty unhappy about it. I was upset.
[叹气] 我可能不该留着。但它对我意义重大。它是开启我做这件事的大门的钥匙。当我不得不刮掉胡子时，我非常难过，我甚至很痛苦。
The next year, Allen bought a fake beard to play Santa. But it looked so bad, he couldn't bring himself to wear it. So two years pass without playing Santa.
第二年，艾伦买了一把假胡子来扮圣诞老人。但那看起来太糟糕了，他实在没法戴出去。于是，又有两年时间没能扮成圣诞老人。
And then, thanks in part to his wife, Erin, who was making enough money as an engineer to support them, Allen is finally able to retire. And he throws himself into becoming Santa.
后来，多亏了他的妻子艾琳（她作为工程师赚的钱足够养活他们），艾伦终于得以退休。他全身心地投入到成为圣诞老人的事业中。
The goal is to become a professional Santa-- the kind that someone might hire for, say, a private party or a parade or-- the Holy Grail of Santa engagements-- a chair gig. First thing-- Allen starts growing his beard back.
目标是成为一名专业的圣诞老人——那种会被人雇佣去参加私人派对、游行，或者圣诞老人界圣杯——“坐镇”工作的人。第一件事，艾伦开始重新留胡子。
Then, he signs up for Santa's school, a weekend intensive where you learn everything, from what to say to skeptical kids to how to make an entrance. He meets lots of other Santas, who offer helpful tips like how to sneak in a bathroom break while staying in character. Apparently, you're supposed to say you have to make a call to the North Pole.
接着，他报名参加了圣诞老人学校，那是一个周末强化班，你可以学到一切，从怎么应付质疑的孩子到如何登场。他结识了许多其他圣诞老人，他们提供了一些实用的窍门，比如如何在保持角色形象的情况下溜去洗手间。显然，你应该说你要给北极打个电话。
Finding out there's this entire world you didn't know about has been a little weird. And sometimes you wonder how you got to this place in life. This is a deeply weird thing for middle-aged and elderly guys to do. But-- but it's kind of wonderful. I mean, it's-- but it's deeply strange at the same time.
发现居然有这样一个我以前从未听说过的世界，感觉真有点奇怪。有时你会纳闷自己是怎么走到这一步的。对于中老年男人来说，这真是件非常古怪的事，但同时，又有一种奇妙的魅力。
By the time I'm talking to him, Allen's spent almost a full year preparing for the role. He's a diligent and serious student of the Santa tradition, but there's one part of it he doesn't believe in-- the naughty list. Surprising, maybe, given his last job.
当我采访他时，艾伦已经为这个角色准备了近一年。他是圣诞老人传统中勤奋而认真的学生，但有一点他不相信——“淘气名单”。考虑到他上一份工作，这可能有点让人惊讶。
You've been bad, you're on the naughty list. That's no way to be.
“你表现不好，所以你在淘气名单上。”这种方式是不对的。
Feels punitive.
感觉像是在惩罚。
Exactly. And that's-- I've seen punitive, and I don't think it works. So I want to be able to lift them up, rather than put them in a corner somewhere and tell them that you're this thing.
没错。我见过惩罚，我不认为它有效。所以我希望能激励他们，而不是把他们关在某个角落，告诉他们“你是那样的人”。
Being Santa lets them work on the other side of the ledger, which feels a lot better to him.
成为圣诞老人让他能够在那本账簿的另一边工作，这让他感觉好多了。
I tried to do that job as well as I could, but you know, it was really difficult. And when you run into a lot of people that are sort of on the naughty list, and you can't do anything for them, and they can't do anything for themselves, it feels kind of hopeless. That's a lesson I learned from my career. People need redemption.
我以前尽我所能做好那份工作，但这真的很难。当你遇到很多处于“淘气名单”上的人，而你却无能为力，他们自己也无法自救时，那种感觉真的很绝望。这是我从职业生涯中获得的教训：人们需要救赎。
They need to be accepted back into the fold, even if they've made mistakes. You know, finding a way to forgive other people sort of gives you an opening to forgive yourself. And there's a box of Kleenex here. [BLOWS NOSE]
他们需要被重新接纳，即使他们犯过错。你知道，找到原谅别人的方法，也为你原谅自己打开了一扇窗。这里有盒纸巾。[擤鼻涕]
The day has finally arrived for Allen's first-ever chair gig. We're driving to the event, which is at an abandoned Pier 1 in an outdoor mall, about a half an hour from his house.
艾伦第一次“坐镇”工作的日子终于到了。我们开车前往目的地，那是一个离他家半小时车程、位于室外购物中心里的一家废弃的 Pier 1 门店。
We hop out of the car and meet Joanna Garcia, who hired Allen for the event. She lets us in through the back door of the building. There's a single clothing rack with T-shirts on it. Allen takes the shirts off, so he can use the rack to hang all the pieces of a Santa outfit. But he's so nervous, he keeps dropping stuff.
我们跳下车，见到了雇佣艾伦的乔安娜·加西亚。她带我们从建筑后门进去。里面只有一个挂 T 恤的架子。艾伦把衣服取下来，好用架子挂他的圣诞老人装束。但他太紧张了，手里的东西掉个不停。
I'm kind of almost jittery. It almost feels like I'm doing slapstick or something. [LAUGHS]
我简直紧张得发抖，感觉像是在表演闹剧一样。[笑]
A line forms outside while Allen changes into his costume. He's got a fur-lined red robe and matching hat and a green vest with gold buttons underneath. He's wearing big black boots and little half-moon spectacles that, I have to say, really pull the whole outfit together.
在艾伦换衣服的时候，门外已经排起了队。他穿上一件红色的毛绒长袍，戴上配套的帽子，里面还穿了一件带金纽扣的绿色背心。他穿着黑色的大靴子，戴着那种半月形小眼镜，我不得不说，这眼镜让整套打扮瞬间立住了。
But he still just looks like a guy in a costume. And then the door is open, and the kids rush in.
但他看起来依然只是个穿着戏服的人。然后门开了，孩子们涌了进来。
[BELLS RINGING]
[铃铛响]
Hello, everyone! Merry Christmas! Ho, ho! I love your dress!
大家好！圣诞快乐！吼、吼！我喜欢你的裙子！
Suddenly, he's Santa. Confident, arms stretched wide, beaming-- whatever the opposite of neurotic is, he is that. Two little girls walk in and spot him, and their eyes seem to double in size, like they're seeing something truly magical. It's clear they have no idea this is his first time doing this. To them, he's Santa.
突然间，他成了圣诞老人。自信、双臂张开、笑容满面——不管神经质的反义词是什么，他现在就是那样。两个小女孩走进来看到他，眼睛似乎瞬间瞪大了一倍，仿佛她们真的看到了奇迹。很明显，她们完全不知道这是他第一次做这件事。对她们来说，他就是圣诞老人。
OK! Are we ready, everybody?
好了！大家都准备好了吗？
Yeah.
准备好了！
The day begins.
这一天开始了。
Do you know what you want for Christmas, sweetheart?
宝贝，你知道你想要什么圣诞礼物吗？
Monster trucks.
怪兽卡车。
Monster trucks? I love monster trucks! [ROARS]
怪兽卡车？我最喜欢怪兽卡车了！[咆哮]
As you can hear, he's got his kid voice on. And I don't know what I expected, exactly, but this job requires just so much pep. Santa Allen is tap-dancing as fast as he can--
如你所听到的，他用上了“孩子腔”。我不知道自己具体期待什么，但这份工作确实需要极大的热情。圣诞老人艾伦正竭尽全力地卖力表演——
(SINGING) Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way.
(唱) 铃儿响叮当，铃儿响叮当，一路叮当响。
--to keep the kids happy and engaged--
为了让孩子们保持快乐和参与度——
Fist bump! Yeah! Blow it up! Boom!
碰拳！耶！加油！嘣！
--so the photographer, Sam, can snap a good picture for the parents.
这样摄影师萨姆才能为家长们拍出一张好照片。
(SINGING) Paw Patrol, Paw Patrol, paw, paw, paw, paw, paw, paw, paw, Paw Patrol!
(唱) 汪汪队，汪汪队，汪、汪、汪、汪、汪、汪、汪，汪汪队！
Watching Santa Allen, I thought about this thing another Santa-- a pastor named Santa Don-- told me. Santa Don said that back when he was in graduate school for psychology, on his first day of class, his professor asked, how many of you have people who are already coming to you for counseling?
看着圣诞老人艾伦，我想到另一位圣诞老人——一位名叫圣诞老人唐的牧师告诉我的话。圣诞老人唐说，当年他在读心理学研究生时，开学第一天，教授问大家：“你们中有多少人已经有人来找你们寻求咨询了？”
Don and a few other students raise their hands. Then the professor goes, I'm going to be honest with you. If people aren't already coming to you, getting a degree from here probably won't change that.
唐和其他几名学生举起了手。教授然后说：“我跟你们说实话吧。如果现在还没人找你们，单凭拿个学位可能也改变不了什么。”
You're either the kind of person people want to confide in, or you're not. Don thinks that the same is true for Santa. There's some innate Santa essence, some Santa vibe, that you either have or you don't.
你要么是那种让人想倾诉的人，要么就不是。唐认为圣诞老人也是这样。有一种天生的圣诞老人本质，某种“圣诞气氛”，要么你有，要么你没有。
And here, on his first chair gig, Santa Allen seemed to have it, though it didn't always go so smoothly with every kid.
在这里，在他的第一次“坐镇”工作中，圣诞老人艾伦似乎拥有这种特质，尽管并不是对每个孩子都那么顺利。
[CHILD CRYING]
[孩子在哭]
(SINGING) Here comes Santa Claus, here comes Santa Claus, right down Santa Claus--
(唱) 圣诞老人来啦，圣诞老人来啦，圣诞老人正朝这里——
[CHILD CONTINUES CRYING]
[孩子继续在哭]
Oh! [LAUGHS]
哦！[笑]
There were a lot of crying babies.
哭闹的婴儿还真不少。
[BABY CRYING]
[婴儿在哭]
Oh! I'm so sorry! We'll get you next year! I'll see you on Christmas Eve, my friend.
哦！真抱歉！我们明年再见！我的朋友，平安夜我会再见到你的。
Sometimes kids asked Santa Allen for things that threw him for a loop, like the boy who said he wanted trouble for Christmas, or the girl who just wanted socks.
有时孩子们会问一些让圣诞老人艾伦不知所措的问题，比如有个男孩说他想要“麻烦”作为圣诞礼物，还有个女孩只想要袜子。
But, like, character socks, right? Good socks? No? Just regular sock socks? OK, that's good.
但是，是那种卡通图案的袜子，对吧？好的那种？不？普通的袜子？好吧，那也不错。
One little girl wanted two hamsters, but as she asked for them, her parents stood behind her with wide eyes, vigorously shaking their heads, no. Of course, there were some awkward moments, like when Santa Allen accidentally mistaked a boy with long hair for a girl. And this kid, who looked like a tiny adult, and who is not having it with Santa Allen's questions--
一个小女孩想要两只仓鼠，但她问的时候，她父母站在身后瞪大眼睛，拼命摇头说不。当然，也有尴尬时刻，比如圣诞老人艾伦不小心把一个长头发的男孩认成了女孩。还有这个孩子，看起来像个小大人，根本不买圣诞老人问题的账——
I have animals. Do you know what kind of animals I have?
我有小动物。你知道我养了什么动物吗？
Uh, the pretend kind.
呃，那种假装的。
No, the real reindeer. They have antlers like this.
不，是真正的驯鹿。它们有长成这样的鹿角。
Yeah, I know. I've seen them on TV.
是啊，我知道。我在电视上见过。
Have you seen Rudolph? Have you seen his nose?
你见过鲁道夫吗？你见过他的鼻子吗？
Yeah, I know. His nose lights up.
见过，我知道。他的鼻子会发光。
Yeah it lights up, and it's red. Are you going to school right now?
是的，它会发光，而且是红色的。你现在在上学吗？
No.
没有。
No?
没有？
I'm barely four.
我才刚四岁。
Oh, some people go to school when they're four.
哦，有些人四岁就开始上学了。
Santa Allen had imagined fielding all these big, hard questions from kids. But in practice, the real work of imitating Santa is more like working in a factory line, a quick back-and-forth, snap a picture, then onto the next. The hardest question he ended up getting was about Mrs. Claus.
圣诞老人艾伦曾想象过自己要应付孩子们各种各样的难题。但实际上，模仿圣诞老人的真正工作更像是工厂流水线，快速的一问一答，拍张照，然后换下一个。他最后遇到的最难的问题是关于圣诞老奶奶的。
I was going to ask you--
我正想问你——
OK.
好。
--if you can ask Mrs. Claus if she actually does bake cookies. So like, if she does, can she send me one?
——如果你能问问圣诞老奶奶，她真的会烤饼干吗？如果她真的烤，能送我一个吗？
I don't-- she doesn't-- she just mostly makes them for the North Pole, but we'll ask. And she is important. She is the CEO of the North Pole. Mrs. Claus is actually my boss.
我不……她不太……她主要是在北极烤，但我们会问问的。而且她很重要，她是北极的 CEO。圣诞老奶奶其实是我的老板。
Allen wanted to yes-and the little girl, but didn't want to promise cookies and set her up to be disappointed on Christmas Day. So instead, he pivoted to a feminist message. He later told me, he wants to update the image of Mrs. Claus for kids, especially for girls. He doesn't like the idea that she just bakes cookies and putters around the North Pole all day.
艾伦想给那个小女孩一个肯定的答复，但又不想承诺饼干结果让她在圣诞节失望。于是他转而传达了一个女权主义的信息。他后来告诉我，他想为孩子们更新圣诞老奶奶的形象，尤其是对女孩们。他不希望她只是整天在北极烤饼干和闲逛。
At 1:00 PM, the doors are closed. Santa Allen's been there for two hours, talked to over 100 kids. He changes out of his costume and into what's referred to as "Santa casual" -- red clothing, but not the whole shebang. Christmas Lite. He packs up, and we get in the car.
下午 1 点，大门关上了。圣诞老人艾伦在那里待了两个小时，与 100 多个孩子聊了天。他换下了戏服，穿上了所谓的“圣诞便装”——红色的衣服，但不是全套的那种，也就是“轻量级圣诞节”。他收拾好东西，我们上了车。
We're about to drive back to his house, when Allen realizes he's left his backpack inside the store. This is a problem for him, because he really doesn't want to go back and get it and have people see him when he's not in the full Santa costume. But as we're walking back to the Pier 1, a guy in a car notices Allen.
我们正要开车回家时，艾伦意识到他把背包落在店里了。这对他来说是个问题，因为他真不想回去取包，不想让人在他没穿全套戏服时看到他。但当我们走回 Pier 1 时，一个开车的人注意到了艾伦。
Santa?
圣诞老人？
Allen puts his finger up to his lips, as if to say, shh!
艾伦把手指放在嘴唇上，好像在说：嘘！
[ALLEN LAUGHS]
[艾伦笑]
I won't say nothing.
我什么都不会说的。
(LAUGHING) OK.
[笑] 好的。
I won't say nothing, the guy says. Then, we're standing in front of the store, waiting to be let back in, when a girl in the backseat of a car driving by yells, Santa!
“我什么都不会说的，”那个人说。接着，我们站在店门前等着被放进去，这时一辆经过的车后座里的女孩尖叫道：“圣诞老人！”
Oh, jeez. I kind of don't want to ruin the image for anybody.
哦，天哪。我有点不想破坏在任何人眼里的形象。
You feel embarrassed.
你感到尴尬了。
I-- yeah.
我……是的。
Allen tries to tuck himself into the corner of the building by the door to hide from people, but it doesn't work. At all. Everyone who passes by double-takes him or yells at him.
艾伦试着把自己缩在店门口的角落里想躲开人们，但完全没用。每一个经过的人都会回头看他，或者对他大喊。
Hey, Santa!
嘿，圣诞老人！
Hi.
嗨。
Allen looks miserable.
艾伦看起来很痛苦。
It's funny, you've transformed back into Allen.
这很有意思，你又变回了艾伦。
I know.
我知道。
Without the robe.
没有长袍。
I know. You love watching me squirm like this.
我知道。你很喜欢看我这样局促不安。
No! I don't. But I'm struck by the transformation.
不！我没有。但我被这种转变震惊了。
Yeah.
是啊。
How different you are.
你完全变了一个人。
I guess I'm back to being Clark Kent or something. I don't know.
我猜我又变回了克拉克·肯特之类的吧，我不知道。
You're literally cowering in a corner. This is not the man I saw 30 minutes ago.
你刚才简直是缩在角落里。这跟我半小时前见到的那个人完全不一样。
I'm-- I'm not him. I'm me.
我……我不是他，我就是我。
Allen did not plan on ending his first chair gig glued to the side of a Pier 1. But there is a part of him, he tells me later, that's relieved to be himself again. All that cheeriness, being so enthusiastically on-- it's exhausting being Santa.
艾伦没计划让他的第一份坐镇工作以缩在 Pier 门店边上结束。但他告诉我，他内心深处其实挺庆幸又能做回自己了。那种欢快、那种热情地保持表演状态——当圣诞老人真的很耗体力。
Aviva DeKornfeld is one of the producers of our show.
阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Two, Jews for Jesus, for Just One Day. For Alex Edelman, it's easy to remember his first Christmas, because it was his only Christmas. He was raised as an Orthodox Jew. And he says his family was very Jewish, casually dropped Hebrew around the house.
第二幕，为耶稣而作的犹太人，只做一天。对于亚历克斯·埃德尔曼来说，记住他的第一个圣诞节很容易，因为那是他唯一的一个圣诞节。他在正统犹太教家庭中长大。他说他的家庭非常传统，家里经常会蹦出希伯来语。
He and his brother, AJ, called their parents Eema and Abba for Mom and Dad. He's a comedian and tells this story about how they were so Jewish and so surrounded by Jews, he didn't even know he was Jewish for a while.
他和哥哥 AJ 叫父母为“Eema”和“Abba”，也就是妈妈和爸爸。他是个喜剧演员，经常讲起他们家如何沉浸在犹太氛围中，以至于他有一段时间甚至不知道自己是犹太人。
And I remember the first time I was aware of being Jewish. I was at a children's birthday party at a Chuck E. Cheese, and I reached for a slice of pizza that had some sausage on it or some pepperoni-- something not kosher. And my grandfather saw me reaching, and he kicked my hand away.
我记得第一次意识到自己是犹太人是在查克芝士（Chuck E. Cheese）的一个儿童派对上，我伸手去拿一片加了香肠或意大利辣香肠的披萨——那是不符合犹太洁食要求的。我祖父看到我伸出手，一把拍开了我的手。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Kicked. And he went, you can't have that! We're Jewish! And I said, what does that mean? And with a totally straight face, he just went, it means you'll never be happy.
踢开了。他说：“你不能吃那个！我们是犹太人！”我问：“那是什么意思？”他一脸严肃地回答：“这意味着你永远不会幸福。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And I went, Papa! I don't want to be Jewish! And then, my grandfather laughed at me and went, ha-ha! Chief, that's the most Jewish thing there is!
我说：“爸爸，我不想当犹太人！”我祖父笑了笑说：“哈哈！孩子，这才是最犹太的事情！”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
When Alex and his brother, AJ, were little, they attended yeshiva, Jewish day school. So like I say, their whole world was people who never celebrated or talked about Christmas. But in the show Alex has been touring, he talks about this one December when he was six and AJ was four.
当亚历克斯和哥哥 AJ 小时候，他们上的是犹太学校。所以我说，他们的整个世界里，都是些从不庆祝或谈论圣诞节的人。但在亚历克斯巡演的节目中，他提到了他六岁、AJ 四岁那年的那个十二月。
He mentions, by the way, a family friend in the story. And he changed her name when he tells the story on stage. Here's Alex.
顺便提一下，他在故事里提到了一位家庭朋友。他在台上讲故事时改了她的名字。这是亚历克斯。
All of the best Jewish moments of my life are moments where Jewish values presented themselves in, like, unconventional places. Like, once, when I was a kid, my family had Christmas. My mom had this friend named Kelly.
我一生中最好的犹太时刻，都是那些犹太价值观在非常规地方展现出来的时候。比如有一次，我还是个孩子时，我家过了圣诞节。我妈有个朋友叫凯莉。
And Kelly had lost her siblings, like, in years previous, and her parents weren't in the picture. She was alone in Boston, and my mom noticed that she would get sad around the holidays. And this was a really good friend, and so my mom said, hey, Kelly, why don't you come to our house for Christmas?
凯莉前几年失去了兄弟姐妹，父母也不在身边。她一个人在波士顿，我妈注意到她每到节日就会变忧郁。这是个很好的朋友，所以我妈说：“嘿，凯莉，为什么今年圣诞节不来我家过呢？”
That's the kind of person my mom was. My father did not want that. My mom is a Jew from Cincinnati. She's a Midwestern Jew. It's a slightly gentler existence.
我妈就是那种人。我父亲当时非常不同意。我妈是辛辛那提来的犹太人，是个中西部的犹太人，生活方式相对温和一点。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
My father grew up Jewish in Boston, like me. But Dad grew up Jewish in Boston in a time when it's actually really hard to be Jewish there, which is between the years 1500 and 1994. He's like, Cheryl, I will not have Christmas in a Jewish home! And she's like, Elazer, we're having Christmas. And he's like, over my dead body are we having Christmas! So they compromised, and we had Christmas.
我父亲像我一样，也是在波士顿长大的犹太人。但他成长的那个年代在波士顿当犹太人其实很艰难，也就是在 1500 年到 1994 年之间。他说：“谢丽尔，我决不允许犹太家庭过圣诞节！”我妈说：“埃拉泽，我们要过圣诞节。”他说：“除非我死了，否则别想过圣诞节！”于是他们妥协了，我们家过了圣诞节。
AJ and I come downstairs one day. My parents are sitting in the living room. I don't know if anyone else grew up in a home like this. We were never allowed, as children, in the living room, never.
有一天 AJ 和我下楼。我父母坐在客厅里。不知道有没有人像我这样长大，我们小时候是不准进客厅的，从来都不准。
The living room was for guests and tragedy. So those are the only times we were allowed. And everything in the living room was covered with, like, a thick plastic sheet, in case, like, the real owners of the home showed up one day.
客厅是留给客人和悲剧发生的。这是我们唯一被允许进入的时候。客厅里所有的东西都盖着一层厚厚的塑料布，就像是怕房子的真正主人哪天会突然回来一样。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
We come downstairs. My parents are in the living room. No guests. And AJ and I look at each other like, oh, no, Bubbe died again. (LAUGHING) And we walk in, and we sit down on the forbidden couch.
我们下楼来。我父母在客厅。没有客人。AJ 和我看着对方，想：哦，不，祖母又去世了。（笑）我们走进去，坐在了那张禁忌的沙发上。
And my mom just went, boys, this year, we're going to have Christmas. And this is how young and insulated we were. AJ and I looked at each other, and we looked at my parents, and I just went, "What's Christmas?"
我妈只是说：“孩子们，今年我们要过圣诞节。”我们当时太年轻、太孤陋寡闻了。AJ 和我看着对方，看着我父母，我问：“什么是圣诞节？”
And my father went-- [SIGHS] "It's like Hanukkah." And my mom undermined him immediately and went, "Yeah but, maybe even a little bit more fun!" Hanukkah sucks! I appreciate the new politically correct world that everybody lives in. We all pretend that all the holidays are equal.
我父亲叹了口气：“就像光明节。”我妈立刻拆台：“是啊，但可能还要再好玩一点！”光明节太烂了！我感谢现在大家生活的这个政治正确的世界，大家都假装所有节日都是平等的。
They are not equal. Everybody knows it. Hanukkah is very much the Diet Coke to Christmas' black tar heroin. There is no comparison. There is no comparison.
它们并不平等。大家都心知肚明。光明节跟圣诞节比起来，简直就像是无糖可乐对黑焦油海洛因。没法比，根本没法比。
And you never know when Hanukkah is, because the calendars-- sometimes it's in early December. Sometimes it's in, like, late July. You never [BLEEP] know. But my non-Jewish friends are always like, well, you guys are lucky. You get eight days of gifts. I have never met a single Jew who has ever received eight days of gifts.
而且你永远不知道光明节什么时候到来，因为日历的原因——有时在十二月初，有时在七月底。你永远不知道。但我的非犹太朋友总是说：“嘿，你们真幸运，有八天的礼物。”我从来没见过哪个犹太人真的收到过八天的礼物。
Here's how it works. You get one gift over the course of the eight days. If you're getting a bike, you get, like, a pedal on the first day, the handlebars the second day, and the wheel on the third day. It is absolute bull-[BLEEP]. Anyway.
其实是这样的：八天里你只能收到一个礼物。如果你想要自行车，第一天给你一个踏板，第二天给你把手，第三天给你一个轮子。这简直是胡扯。总之。
We do Christmas, and oh my god, do we do Christmas. We do the lights. We do the stockings and glitter. We went whole hog-- no hog. Kosher Christmas dinner. But we deck these goddamn halls. Deck.
我们过了圣诞节，噢，上帝，我们过得太彻底了。我们挂了灯，准备了长筒袜和亮片。我们倾其所有——没有猪肉，犹太洁食圣诞大餐。但我们把大厅装饰得神圣极了。
And Kelly comes into our house, and Kelly-- white, WASP, like Princess Diana haircut, chunky gold earrings, Hermes scarf, shocking blue pantsuit-- white. But she walks into her house like a little kid. And she starts to cry immediately.
凯莉走进我家，她是一个白人，典型的新教徒，戴安娜王妃式的发型，厚重的金耳环，爱马仕围巾，惊艳的蓝色裤套装。她走进来时就像个小孩子。她立刻就开始哭了。
And my mom just went, boys, whatever Kelly wants to do, we're going to do. And we did all this deep-cuts Christmas stuff. Like, we strung popcorn together on a string. We ate our way through the entire chocolate advent calendar in, like, 25 minutes.
我妈就说：“孩子们，不管凯莉想做什么，我们都要配合。”于是我们做了所有圣诞节的传统项目。比如我们用线把爆米花串起来，在 25 分钟内吃完了整盒巧克力倒数日历。
And we watched Christmas movies. Please try to imagine being a young Jew who has never seen a single Christmas movie. And then one day, you watch, like, seven of them in a row. AJ and I are like, what is this! And the one that sticks out is the Peanuts Christmas special.
我们还看了圣诞电影。请想象一下，一个从未看过圣诞电影的犹太男孩，突然一天连看了七部。AJ 和我当时想：这是什么东西！印象最深的是《花生》圣诞特辑。
Snoopy, Charlie Brown-- AJ and I are, like, pressed up against screen. We're, like, vibrating with joy, and it's like, the meaning of Christmas, Snoopy! I'm like, the spirit of Christmas, Charlie Brown! My dad's in the corner, like, praying for lightning. And, like--
史努比、查理·布朗——AJ 和我紧贴着屏幕。我们激动得颤抖，我觉得这就是圣诞节的意义，史努比！我觉得这就是圣诞精神，查理·布朗！我爸在角落里祈祷雷电劈下来……
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
At some point, Kelly, crying, walks over to us, and she's like, boys, we need to put out cookies for Santa Claus, don't we? And AJ and I are like, uh-huh! And we look at my dad, who's already covering his face, and I just went, "Aba! Who's Santa Claus?"
过了一会儿，凯莉一边哭一边走过来，对我们说：“孩子们，我们得为圣诞老人留些饼干，对吧？”AJ 和我大喊：“嗯！”我们看着已经在捂脸的父亲，我问：“爸爸！圣诞老人是谁？”
And my father rarely cursed in front of us. And my mother says she doesn't think this happened, but I remember so clearly-- and maybe he thought we couldn't hear him. My father looked at my mom, and he went, "Cheryl! Jesus [BLEEP] Christ!"
我父亲很少在我们面前咒骂。但我妈说她不记得发生过这事，但我记得非常清楚——也许他以为我们听不见。我父亲看着我妈，冒出一句：“谢丽尔！该死的耶稣基督！”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And my mom went, "Elazer!" And he went, "Come on!" And she went, "Do it!"
我妈说：“埃拉泽！”他说：“够了！”她说：“做吧！”
My father walked up to us, and he went, "Santa Claus, boys-- he is a fat man.
我父亲走到我们面前说：“圣诞老人，孩子们——他是个胖子。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And he comes down non-Jewish chimneys in the middle of the night, and he gives gifts to young gentiles."
“他在深夜从非犹太人的烟囱里钻进来，把礼物送给年轻的非犹太人。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And he said, "He's like Elijah. But instead of drinking your wine, he eats cookies and leaves you gifts." If you don't know who Elijah is, on Passover, the Jewish holiday, in my house, here's what will happen.
他说：“他就像先知以利亚。但他不喝你的酒，而是吃饼干，并留下礼物。”如果你不知道以利亚是谁，在逾越节，也就是犹太节日时，我家里会发生这样的事：
Your uncle will open the door for Elijah. And then, one of the other uncles under the table will start kicking the table. When the wine cup shakes, they'll go, look, he's drinking! He's drinking!
你叔叔会为以利亚打开门。然后，桌底下的另一个叔叔会开始踢桌子。当酒杯晃动时，他们会喊：“看，他在喝酒！他在喝酒！”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And AJ and I look at each other. And we look at my dad. And AJ just went, "B'emet?" Which means, "For real?" And my father looked at my mom, and he looked at us, and he went, "Yeah, of course he's real."
AJ 和我看着对方。我们看着我爸。AJ 问：“B'emet？”也就是“真的吗？”我父亲看着我妈，看着我们，说：“当然，他当然是真的。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
We put out cookies for Santa Claus. I remember every little detail, little table, red tablecloth, Power Rangers plate, three chocolate chip cookies. We're very skeptical, obviously.
我们为圣诞老人放好了饼干。我还记得每一个小细节，小桌子，红色桌布，恐龙战队盘子，三块巧克力曲奇。显然，我们当时是非常怀疑的。
We go upstairs. We go to bed. We come downstairs the next morning. The cookies are gone! They're gone! And AJ and I see this, and we black out completely.
我们上楼去睡觉。第二天早上我们下楼。饼干没了！真的没了！AJ 和我看到这一幕，当场石化。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
We, like, lose consciousness. But I know what's happened, because I saw home videos a couple of years ago, and on them, we're like, oh, my god! Oh, my god! He was here! He was here!
我们甚至失去了意识。但我知道发生了什么，因为几年后我看到了家庭录像。录像里我们尖叫：“噢，天哪！噢，天哪！他来过了！他真的来过了！”
And at some point, AJ is standing on the couch, and he looked at me, and he just went, "Santa came!" And I went, "Baruch HaShem!"
录像里 AJ 站在沙发上，看着我说：“圣诞老人来了！”我说：“Baruch HaShem！”（上帝保佑）
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And we ran out to the garage. Why? This is the one concession my father got from my mom. He's like, Cheryl, I will not have a Christmas tree in a Jewish home. And she's like, I can respect that, Elazer. We'll put it in the garage.
我们跑向车库。为什么？这是我父亲从我母亲那里争取到的唯一让步。他说：“谢丽尔，我决不允许犹太人家里有圣诞树。”我妈说：“我可以尊重这一点，埃拉泽。我们把它放在车库里。”
And there are two photos of this. They're the weirdest photos. We're wearing jackets, because we're in a Boston garage in December. We're wearing pajamas, because we're children. And we're wearing yarmulkes, because we're Jews. But we're standing in front of a fully-decorated Christmas tree with a teddy bear on the top, holding a dreidel and wearing a yarmulke!
有两张关于这的照片。那是些最怪异的照片：我们穿着外套，因为那是十二月的波士顿车库；我们穿着睡衣，因为还是孩子；我们戴着基帕（犹太小帽），因为我们是犹太人。但我们站在一棵装饰齐全的圣诞树前，树顶挂着一只泰迪熊，我手里拿着一个陀螺，头上戴着基帕！
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And we go to yeshiva that day, because Jewish day school, if you can believe it-- not canceled for Christmas. And we come home that night, and my father gets a phone call. It's exactly what you think.
那天我们去了犹太学校，因为如果是圣诞节，犹太学校是不放假的。那天晚上我们回家，父亲接到了一个电话。内容正如你所想。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And he picks it up. And the first thing the principal says to him is, Professor Edelman! Your sons have a lying problem! My father said, what did they do? And the principal said, well, the teacher tried to explain to the children the very delicate topic of Christmas.
他接起电话，校长说的第一句话是：“埃德尔曼教授！你儿子有撒谎的问题！”我父亲问：“他们做什么了？”校长说：“老师试图向孩子们解释圣诞节这个敏感话题。”
And Alex raised his hand, and he said, we had Christmas. And the teacher said, you didn't have Christmas. And he said, hmm, I'm pretty sure we had Christmas. Lights, stockings, Snoopy, Charlie Brown, meaning of Christmas--
“然后亚历克斯举起手说：‘我们家过了圣诞节。’老师说：‘你们没过圣诞节。’他说：‘唔，我很确定我们过了。挂了灯，有长筒袜，有史努比、查理·布朗，还有圣诞节的意义……’”
And the teacher's like, you didn't have Christmas. You had Hanukkah, three weeks ago or nine months from now, depending on the year. Anyway, non-Jews believe in this guy, called Santa Claus.
“老师说：‘你们没过圣诞节。你们过了光明节，那是三周前或者九个月后，视年份而定。总之，非犹太人相信有个叫圣诞老人的人。’”
And in my mind's eye, I remember AJ raising his hand and saying, we had Santa Claus. That's what I remember. But there are conflicting accounts here.
而在我的记忆里，我记得 AJ 举手说：“我们过了圣诞节。”这是我记忆中的版本。但这里有相互冲突的说法。
Apparently, AJ didn't raise his hand. Apparently, AJ, in the words of the teacher, lifted two fingers, like he was ordering a second Martini. And AJ didn't say, we had Santa Claus. Apparently, AJ just went, we know Santa Claus.
显然 AJ 没有举手。显然，在老师的描述中，AJ 竖起了两根手指，就像是在点第二杯马提尼。而且 AJ 没说“我们过了圣诞节”。显然 AJ 说的是：“我们认识圣诞老人。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
And the teacher's like, you don't know Santa Claus, AJ! And AJ's like, mmm, pretty sure I know Santa Claus. And the other kids are like, who's Santa Claus? AJ's like, oh! He's amazing! He's a fat man, and he comes down non-Jewish chimneys in the middle of the night, and he gives gifts to the young gentiles.
老师说：“你不认识圣诞老人，AJ！”AJ 说：“嗯，我很确定我认识圣诞老人。”其他孩子问：“谁是圣诞老人？”AJ 说：“噢！他太棒了！他是个胖子，深夜从非犹太人的烟囱里钻进来，把礼物送给年轻的非犹太人。”
He's like Elijah, but instead of wine, there's cookies and gifts. But last night, because he's friends with our dad--
“他就像以利亚，但不是喝酒，而是吃饼干和送礼物。但昨晚，因为他是我爸的朋友——”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
--he came down our chimney, and he left this Walkman underneath the tree that my parents put in the garage, and he ate all of the cookies! The principal said, Professor Edelman, is this true? And apparently, my father just went, no. It's not entirely true.
“——他从我们烟囱钻下来，把这台随身听留在车库里的圣诞树下，还把所有的饼干都吃了！”校长问：“埃德尔曼教授，这是真的吗？”显然我父亲回答：“不，不完全是真的。”
And the principal said, what do you mean it's not entirely true? And my father said, Cheryl and I ate the cookies.
校长问：“什么叫不完全是真的？”我父亲说：“谢丽尔和我吃了饼干。”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
AJ's wrong. Santa didn't come to our house. And my mom says there was a significant pause on the other end of the phone. And then, the principal went, I know Santa didn't come to your house!
“AJ 错了。圣诞老人没来我们家。”我妈说电话那头沉默了许久。然后校长说：“我知道圣诞老人没来你们家！”
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[观众笑声]
Yet, Christmas? My father explained. He explained that Kelly was bereft and that she had nowhere to go, and that he had reservations about this. But he let it happen, because he thought it was actually a really valuable, teachable moment, where you could explain to his children that doing the thing centered in Jewish values may not always appear conventionally Jewish.
那圣诞节呢？我父亲解释说，凯莉当时非常无助，无处可去，他虽然有所顾虑，但还是让它发生了。因为他觉得这是一个非常有价值的教育时刻，可以教孩子理解：做符合犹太价值观的事，并不一定总是看起来像传统的犹太行为。
And more than anything else, doing this for this woman, who really had nowhere to go, really-- it was a classic example of what Jews would traditionally call mitzvah, which means good deed. Principal listens, Dad explains. My dad finishes.
而且最重要的是，为这个无处可去的女人做这件事，是犹太传统中“善行”（Mitzvah）的经典例子。校长听着，我爸解释着，我爸讲完了。
The principal said, Professor Edelman, I understand where you're coming from, but you're wrong. Because what you've actually done is you've introduced this holiday that is foreign and corrosive into your home. And you've clearly confused your children, and perhaps harmed them permanently.
校长说：“埃德尔曼教授，我理解你的初衷，但你错了。因为你实际上做的是把这个外来的、腐蚀性的节日引入了你的家。你显然搞混了你的孩子，也许还造成了永久性的伤害。”
Well, you've given them this holiday, and next year, you're going to take it away from them. So what's that going to do? This isn't a good deed. This isn't a mitzvah. It's idol worship, which is the most grievous sin that a Jew can possibly commit.
“你给了他们这个节日，明年你又得把它夺走，那会怎么样？这不是善行。这是偶像崇拜，这是犹太人可能犯下的最严重的罪行。”
And you and your wife need to begin repenting for that right now. And my father, to his credit, went-- well, clearly, rabbi, you don't understand the meaning of Christmas. And then, he hung up the phone.
“你和你妻子现在就需要开始忏悔。”我父亲回敬道：“好吧，看来校长你不懂圣诞节的意义。”然后他就挂断了电话。
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]
[观众掌声]
Alex Edelman, with an excerpt of his one-man show, Just For Us, has taken the show to London in January. To find out when he's bringing the show to your city, go to AlexEdelmancomedy.com. The radio excerpt of his story was produced for our show by Aviva DeKornfeld.
亚历克斯·埃德尔曼，单人秀《Just For Us》的节选。该剧已于一月在伦敦上演。要查找他何时来到你的城市，请访问 AlexEdelmancomedy.com。他的这个电台故事节选由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德为我们制作。
Coming up-- the hottest, sexiest parts of It's a Wonderful Life, and other revelations about a very old film from a first-time viewer. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来——《风云人物》（It's a Wonderful Life）中最火辣、最性感的部分，以及一位初次观看者的其他发现。稍后，芝加哥公共电台节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- Baby's First Christmas. Stories of people trying something for the very first time at Christmas, and what that does for them. We've arrived at Act Three of our show, Act Three, Buffalo Gals, Can't You Come Out Tonight?
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——《宝宝的第一个圣诞节》。故事关于人们在圣诞节第一次尝试某事，以及这给他们带来的影响。我们来到节目的第三幕，《水牛城的姑娘，你今晚不出来跳舞吗？》。
So in this story, the new experience that somebody is having at Christmas is simple. We have a grown man, a man who loves films-- classic films, obscure films, new films, all kinds of films-- and he's seen tons of them-- who, somehow, has never seen the most pervasive movie that's out there at Christmas-- It's a Wonderful Life.
在这个故事中，某人圣诞节的新体验很简单。有一位成年男子，他热爱电影——经典片、小众片、新片，什么都看——他看过了无数电影，却不知为何从未看过圣诞期间最普及的那部影片——《风云人物》。
That man-- somebody who's been on the show a bunch, one of our former producers, Neil Drumming. Our executive editor, Emanuele Berry, is, in real life, friends with Neil, and took it upon herself to change his life forever, or possibly not at all, and show him the film.
那个人——我们节目的常客，我们的前制作人尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming）。我们的执行编辑埃曼努埃尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）在现实生活中是尼尔的朋友，她自告奋勇要改变他的人生，或者可能什么也不会改变，并带他看了这部电影。
I've watched a lot of movies with Neil. It's fun, because he gets so giddy and excited about showing you a movie you haven't seen. You always know you're going to have a thoughtful conversation afterwards.
我和尼尔看过很多电影。这很有趣，因为他会兴高采烈地向你展示他没看过的电影。事后你们总能进行一场深刻的交流。
But I also sometimes hate it-- like when he recites all the dialogue in Dazed and Confused while you're trying to watch it. So how'd he miss this movie that's been on television every year since he was born?
但我有时也讨厌这一点——比如当你试图看《年少轻狂》（Dazed and Confused）时，他却在旁边背诵所有的台词。那么，他是怎么错过这部从他出生起每年都在电视上播放的电影的呢？
I really-- I feel like the Christmas movies that I love are the movies with Christmas in the background, like all British movies. But, like, Love Actually, or Die Hard, or like-- movies with Christmas in that background, Christmas in the foreground-- like, I've never seen the one with the little kid with the glasses?
我真的……我觉得我喜欢的圣诞电影是那种背景里有圣诞节的，比如所有的英国电影。比如《真爱至上》（Love Actually），或者是《虎胆龙威》（Die Hard）。但我从来没看过那个戴眼镜的小男孩演的那部……
A Christmas Story?
《圣诞故事》（A Christmas Story）？
Yeah. But, like, the movies that are just Christmas-- I just didn't have an inclination to see them. I think it's because Christmas, for me, was always in the background. Like, I was a Jehovah's Witness, so Christmas was like a thing that happened around me.
对。但那种纯圣诞节的电影，我就是没兴趣。我觉得是因为对我来说，圣诞节一直是在背景里的。因为我是耶和华见证人，所以圣诞节就像是发生在我身边的一件事。
No Christmas tree, no Christmas carols, no Christmas movies. Given that--
没有圣诞树，没有圣诞颂歌，没有圣诞电影。鉴于此——
what is your favorite Christmas movie-- Christmas-in-the-background movie, I guess, is what we're calling them.
我想我们大概可以称之为“背景圣诞节电影”，你最喜欢哪一部？
I think Die Hard is clearly my favorite Christmas movie. I mean, I hate to be so traditional, like, as a male--
我想《虎胆龙威》显然是我最喜欢的圣诞电影。我是说，作为一个男人，我讨厌这么传统……
(LAUGHING) So traditional.
[笑] 这么传统。
I mean, because a lot of men-- a lot of people-- a lot of men will say that Die Hard is their favorite Christmas movie. It is--
因为很多男人——很多人都会说《虎胆龙威》是他们最喜欢的圣诞电影。它是——
Is it just your favorite movie?
那这是你最喜欢的电影吗？
It is in my top 5, consistently.
它一直都在我的前五名之内。
Neil, you see, is a classic example of the problem. I think there's a world of people out there who haven't seen It's a Wonderful Life, because their impression is it's just some corny Hallmark-y movie. Weirdly, I think the most popular Christmas movie out there is also somehow the most underrated by people like Neil.
你看，尼尔就是这个问题的典型例子。我觉得世界上有很多人没看过《风云人物》，因为他们印象里觉得那是一部庸俗的“霍尔马克风格”的电影。奇怪的是，我认为最受欢迎的圣诞电影，在尼尔这样的人眼里，却是被低估最严重的。
To be upfront about this-- I love It's a Wonderful Life. I love the romance of it, the darkness, the humor. I love Jimmy Stewart, the lead actor, and his bumbling charm. Zuzu's petals, the broken banister-- I love it all.
坦白说——我爱《风云人物》。我爱它的浪漫、黑暗和幽默。我爱主演吉米·斯图尔特，爱他笨拙的魅力。祖祖的花瓣，那道断了的扶手——我全爱。
It's not just my favorite Christmas film. It's my favorite film. And I want Neil to see what I see.
它不仅是我最喜欢的圣诞电影，也是我最喜欢的电影。我想让尼尔看到我所看到的。
What do you know about It's a Wonderful Life?
关于《风云人物》，你知道些什么？
It's a Christmas movie, because it happened-- it's always on the air during Christmas.
它是一部圣诞电影，因为在圣诞节期间它总是在电视上播。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
But-- and I know-- I think Macy's is involved or something.
但我知道……我想梅西百货可能参与其中什么的。
Wrong. Here's what else he thinks he knows. Jimmy Stewart, it's in black and white, and he saw something on Instagram that it's about a person losing everything.
错了。他觉得自己还知道：吉米·斯图尔特，黑白片，他在 Instagram 上看到过关于它讲的是一个人失去了一切。
Which makes me think it's, like, maybe some kind of, like, yuletide retelling of the Job story?
这让我觉得它可能是什么约伯记故事的圣诞翻拍版？
OK.
好吧。
I don't know. That's a guess.
我不知道。瞎猜的。
Another reason It's a Wonderful Life holds a special place in my heart-- the ending of the film actually makes me get a little teary. I'm not a crier. I'm embarrassed by the idea of a film making me cry.
《风云人物》在我心中占有特殊地位的另一个原因是——电影结尾真的让我有点泪目。我不是个爱哭的人。电影让我哭这种事让我觉得难为情。
But for lots of people, I think It's a Wonderful Life sneaks up on you.
但对许多人来说，我觉得《风云人物》总是悄无声息地触动你。
Do you think you will cry?
你觉得你会哭吗？
I mean, I absolutely will not cry. The only movie I can think of that I cried at was, like-- it was a Will Smith movie, where he played, like, a poor father once. I can't remember the name of that movie.
我是说，我绝对不会哭。我能想到的唯一让我哭的电影，是……那是威尔·史密斯演的，他演一个可怜的父亲。我不记得电影名了。
Pursuit of Happiness?
《当幸福来敲门》（Pursuit of Happyness）？
Yes, Pursuit of Happiness.
对，《当幸福来敲门》。
You cried during Pursuit of--
你在《当幸福来敲门》时哭了？
Because he had this thing-- he had some long speech about failure as a man, and--
因为他有那一段……关于作为一个男人失败的长篇大论，而且——
Oh, wow, I think-- I don't know, if-- you might cry, Neil.
噢，哇，我想……我不知道，尼尔，你可能会哭的。
Yeah, OK. It's-- I mean, OK, that was a few years ago. Let's see if-- if there is a long speech about failing as a man, then maybe I'll cry. Because that's a subject close to my heart.
是啊，好吧。我是说，那已经是几年前的事了。让我们看看如果……如果里面也有关于作为男人失败的长篇大论，也许我会哭。因为那是触动我内心深处的话题。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
We start the film. In case you, like Neil, haven't seen it, the movie is about George Bailey, a bright, goofy, and friendly young man who wants to see the world but keeps getting stuck in his hometown. First, it's a job that keeps him there. His father passes, and he takes his place running the family business.
电影开始了。如果你和尼尔一样没看过，这部电影讲的是乔治·贝利，一个开朗、古怪又友善的年轻人，他想环游世界却总是被困在家乡。最初是一个工作把他留在了那里：父亲去世，他接手了家族生意。
Then, it's a romance. George meets Mary at a dance where they fall into a pool. And they're forced to walk home in whatever dry clothing they can wrangle together. Mary is in a bathrobe, and George is in a football uniform three sizes too big.
接着是一段罗曼史。乔治在一个舞蹈派对上遇见了玛丽，他们掉进了泳池，被迫只能披着找到的干衣服走回家。玛丽裹着浴袍，乔治穿着大三个尺码的橄榄球服。
(SINGING) Buffalo gal, can't you come out tonight and dance by--
(唱) 水牛城的姑娘，你今晚不出来……
Neil loves a romcom, a good meet-cute.
尼尔喜欢浪漫喜剧，喜欢这种宿命般的相遇。
You know, if it wasn't me talking, I'd say you were the prettiest girl in town.
你知道，如果不是我自己在说，我会说你是全镇最美的女孩。
Well, why don't you say it?
那你为什么不说出来呢？
Oh, I don't know. Maybe I will say it.
噢，我不知道。也许我会说的。
This is hot. It's hot! This is hot!
这太火辣了。太火辣了！这太热了！
(LAUGHING) What do you mean?
[笑] 你是什么意思？
It's hot! This is a hot meet-cute! This is hot!
这太火辣了！这种初次相遇太性感了！
It's a very good meet-cute.
这是一个非常棒的相遇。
Am I talking too much?
我话太多了吗？
Yes!
是的！
[NEIL AND EMANUELE LAUGH]
[笑]
Why don't you kiss her instead of talking her to death?
你为什么不吻她，而不是一直说到死呢？
How's that?
这样呢？
Why don't you kiss her, instead of talking her to death?
为什么不吻她，而是说到死呢？
This is wild sexy. This is amazing to me. This is so hot to me.
这太性感了。这让我非常震撼。对我来说这太火辣了。
[EMANUELE LAUGHS]
[笑]
Oh! Youth is wasted on the wrong people.
噢！青春真是浪费在错误的人身上了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The chemistry between the two leads on this fateful walk home-- I can tell Neil's at least somewhat sold. George and Mary get married. And just when George is about to get out of town, travel with his wife, there's a bank run.
男女主角在回家的宿命之路上产生的化学反应——我能看出尼尔至少有点被打动了。乔治和玛丽结婚了。就在乔治即将离开小镇、与妻子旅行时，发生了银行挤兑。
Then, after that-- a war.
在那之后——是战争。
Then came a war.
接着是战争。
Each time, he's faced with another obstacle. Restuck, he sticks around, tries to fix it-- until one fateful Christmas Eve. His business is about to go under because of a careless mistake made by one of his employees, but George is the one who will be held responsible. He's lost, feels like he has no place to turn. He goes home. Mary and the kids are decorating for Christmas, and he snaps.
每一次他都面临障碍。被困住，留下，试图修复——直到那个决定性的平安夜。他的生意因为员工的一个疏忽就要倒闭了，但责任人却是乔治。他迷失了，感到无路可走。他回家。玛丽和孩子们正在布置圣诞节，他崩溃了。
George, what's wrong?
乔治，你怎么了？
Wrong? Everything's wrong. You call this a happy family? Why do we have to have all these kids?
怎么了？一切都糟透了。你管这叫幸福家庭？为什么我们要生这么多孩子？
Ooh! Damn!
噢！该死！
Not so Merry Christmas-y, is it, Neil?
不像是个圣诞快乐的日子，对吧，尼尔？
I'm with it. Let's get darker. Let go to see how dark this gets. I'm on board. Let's go darker. This is horrible.
我带入进去了。让我们更黑暗点吧。看看这能有多黑暗。我加入了。更黑暗点。这太可怕了。
[EMANUELE LAUGHS]
[笑]
George wishes he'd never been born, and an angel named Clarence makes his wish come true.
乔治许愿他从未出生过，天使克拉伦斯实现了他的愿望。
Is that your wish?
那是你的愿望吗？
He sees what the town would be like if he didn't exist, and it's horrible-- ruled by money-grubbing robber barons. Nobody has jobs or hope.
他看到了如果没有他，小镇会是什么样：那是可怕的——被贪婪的强盗大亨统治，没人有工作，没人有希望。
What's going on around here?
这儿到底发生了什么？
Neil points out, it's very much like a film he has seen-- Back to the Future. Only then does George realize the impact his life has made and that he, in fact, had a wonderful life. Sorry, I couldn't help myself.
尼尔指出，这和一部他看过的电影非常像——《回到未来》（Back to the Future）。只有在那时，乔治才意识到他的人生所产生的影响，以及他实际上拥有一个精彩的人生。抱歉，我忍不住。
Help me, Clarence!
救救我，克拉伦斯！
Clarence takes back George's wish. He runs home to his family, and then everyone in town shows up and gives him money so his business will survive.
克拉伦斯收回了乔治的愿望。他跑回家见家人，镇上所有人都赶来给了他钱，好让他的生意活下来。
Very nearly, George! Very nearly. She told some people you were in trouble. They scattered all over town, collecting money. Didn't ask any questions. Just heard George is in trouble and--
真惊险，乔治！太惊险了。她告诉大家你遇到麻烦了。他们分散到镇上收集钱，没问任何问题。只是听说乔治有难——
Well, these--
嗯，这些——
Another run on the bank?
又一次银行挤兑？
I look over at Neil. No tears. But when the film ends, he tells me that he liked it, and he was surprised by it, and recognized that it was not just a Christmas film.
我看向尼尔。没有眼泪。但当电影结束时，他告诉我他很喜欢，而且很惊讶，意识到这不仅仅是一部圣诞电影。
I definitely forgot it was a Christmas movie. I stopped thinking about it as Christmas. It doesn't feel that-- like, that doesn't feel like what it's about. Until they sing.
我绝对忘了这是一部圣诞电影。我不再把它当成圣诞节电影来想。它给人的感觉——它讲的根本不是关于圣诞节的。直到他们唱起歌来。
I thought it was so funny when you were saying at the beginning that you were like, oh, yeah, I like Christmas movies where Christmas is in the background. I was like, yeah, this is one of those films, actually.
我觉得很有意思的是，开头你说你喜欢背景里有圣诞节的电影，当时我就在想，嗯，其实这电影就是其中之一。
Yeah, yeah. Even the "Auld Lang Syne" is, to me, a New Year's thing. It's like, the Christmas part-- it doesn't really come back to Christmas. It's not, like, about that.
是啊，是啊。就连《友谊地久天长》对我来说也是新年歌曲。所以圣诞节的部分——它并没有真正回到圣诞节。这不是它的核心。
You know what it's like a lot? It's like Die Hard.
你知道它多像什么吗？它很像《虎胆龙威》。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
OK, OK. Say more.
好吧，好吧。多说说。
OK, they both-- the theme of both of them is to, like-- that things aren't as bad as you think. It's that your life could-- that if you stop and appreciate your life-- not even just appreciate. It's not just that you stop and appreciate your life.
它们俩的主题都是——事情并没有你想象的那么糟。这就是如果你停下来欣赏你的人生——甚至不仅仅是欣赏，不仅仅是停下来欣赏你的人生。
It's that circumstance, dire circumstance, forces you to appreciate your life. So in Die Hard, like, a series of ridiculously absurd terrorist-type events makes it so that he appreciates his marriage and his family more. And he fights to save it. That's what I love about that movie.
而是说严峻的情况强迫你去欣赏你的人生。在《虎胆龙威》里，一系列荒谬的恐怖袭击事件让主角更加珍惜他的婚姻和家庭。他为之战斗。这就是我最喜欢那部电影的地方。
That's literally the thing I love the most about that movie is how it is kind of a romantic film. Like, it's like, wait, everything I had was great. I should go back and save it.
我最喜欢的一点就是它其实是一部浪漫电影。就像是：等等，我拥有的一切都很棒。我应该回去拯救它。
And this is that same thing of just, like, in the moment, when things are bad, you can feel like it wasn't worth it. But if you stop and look at it, it's worth saving. It's worth preserving.
这和那是一样的：在当下，事情很糟时，你会觉得不值得。但如果你停下来看看，它是值得拯救的，值得守护的。
It's the end of the year. Like, maybe these kinds of movies are supposed to remind us that, like, amongst all the things you did wrong, there's something-- there's, like-- it's ultimately worth it. I don't know.
这是一年终了。也许这类电影是为了提醒我们，在你做错的所有事情中间，还是有某种东西……它们最终是值得的。我不知道。
But maybe that's a common theme of, like, movies that air at the end of the year. Like, maybe we just want to be reassured, going into the next year, that what we did wasn't completely a waste of time.
但也许这是年末播放的电影的一个共同主题。也许在进入下一年之前，我们只是想要得到保证：我们所做的一切并非完全是在浪费时间。
At one point while we're talking about the film, Neil asked why I cry at that moment the townspeople come out to support George. And I say, it's nice to think that people might recognize all that you do for them. Neil tells me, maybe that's why I'm emotional-- because I do a lot for other people.
当我们在讨论电影时，尼尔问我为什么镇民们出来支持乔治的那一刻我会哭。我说，想到人们可能会认可你为他们所做的一切，这种感觉真好。尼尔告诉我，也许这就是我为什么感性的原因——因为我为别人做了很多。
And Neil says maybe that's why he's not so emotional. Because, well, he doesn't. Not news to me. Case in point, what I did for him this Christmas-- gave him the gift of watching It's a Wonderful Life. What he did for me-- got me to watch Die Hard.
尼尔说也许这就是他为什么没那么感性的原因。因为，嗯，他没怎么做。这对我来说不是新闻。举个例子，这个圣诞节我为他做了什么——给了他看《风云人物》的礼物。他为我做了什么——让我看了《虎胆龙威》。
Emanuele Berry is our show's executive editor.
埃曼努埃尔·贝里是我们节目的执行编辑。
Act Four, Single Bells. Scaachi Koul is celebrating a Christmas first of her own this year, one that she is still puzzling through. Here she is.
第四幕，单身铃声。斯卡奇·考尔（Scaachi Koul）今年也在庆祝她自己的第一个圣诞节，对此她还在苦思冥想。有请。
My marriage was over by last Christmas, but I didn't notice, because I was having such a nice time. One of my ex's many radiant qualities was how much he liked the holidays-- always in stark contrast to me, a misery gremlin who recently escaped a bog and is allergic to natural sunlight.
去年的圣诞节时我的婚姻就已经结束了，但我没注意到，因为那时我过得很开心。我的前任拥有许多闪光品质，其中之一就是他有多么喜欢节日——这总是与我形成鲜明对比，我是一个刚从泥潭逃出来的、对自然阳光过敏的苦难怪兽。
I didn't really grow up celebrating Christmas. I was raised Hindu by immigrants who just didn't really care about the holiday. The extent of our decorations was a sparse plastic tree with screwed-in branches that looked like if a spruce had recently been set ablaze. Our family's dedication to the holiday was always cartoonishly pathetic.
我小时候并不怎么过圣诞节。我是在移民家庭中长大的印度教徒，他们根本不在乎节日。我们的装饰程度仅仅是一棵稀疏的塑料树，那些插上去的树枝看起来像是云杉被烧过一样。我们家对节日的投入总是滑稽可怜。
But when I met my ex a little over 10 years ago, I realized that being with him meant being with a Christmas person. It was like joining a cult where the belief structure was built around a glazed ham. Being with him meant we bought a real, live tree, year after year, filling our apartment with pine needles that I'd find until we bought the next real, live tree.
但十多年前遇到他时，我意识到和他在一起就意味着和“圣诞人”在一起。这就像加入了一个信仰结构建立在冰糖火腿之上的邪教。和他在一起意味着我们要年复一年地买一棵真正的活树，让我们的公寓里充满松针，直到我们买下一棵新的为止。
"Doesn't it smell great?" he'd say. And I'd reply with, no, because years of cigarette smoking has robbed me of a sense of smell. My ex-husband was practically competitive about gift-giving, always giving me the best gift, the thing I wanted, sometimes even the several things I wanted.
“闻起来是不是很棒？”他会问。我会回答：“不，因为多年抽烟让我失去了嗅觉。”我的前夫在送礼物方面简直很有好胜心，总是给我最好的、我想要的，有时甚至是我想要的一大堆东西。
One year, he took me to Cuba. Another year, he bought me a Nintendo console that had been reliably sold out for months. The year after that-- delicate diamond studs for my non-deserving ears. I got him a bag, like, three times. Just three different bags.
有一年他带我去了古巴。有一年他给我买了那款连续好几个月都卖断货的任天堂游戏机。后来那一年——给我那双不配戴钻石的小耳朵买了精致的耳钉。我呢？我送过他三次包，就是三个不同的包。
I don't know. You seem to need a lot of bags. I don't know what I'm doing out here. OK?
我不知道。你看起来好像很需要包。我不知道我在这里做什么。好吗？
I resented Christmas and his love for it often. We used to fight about how I wanted to go see my family for the holidays, even though there wasn't much of a holiday to speak of, and how he wanted to go back to his sleepy little hometown with a three-car Santa Claus parade, and his stepmother's gingerbread village that the grandchildren bickered over, and the minced sauce with his dad's lamb, and the Christmas brunch with his mother.
我经常怨恨圣诞节和他对圣诞节的热爱。我们过去常吵架，因为我过节想看望家人，尽管没什么可过的；而他想回到那个有三辆车参加圣诞老人游行、继母家孩子们争抢姜饼村、还有配羊排的酱汁、以及和他妈妈一起吃圣诞早午餐的小镇。
I was always fighting against my instincts to hate everything, to be cynical, to ask to be left alone. I didn't like Christmas because it required so much sincerity and emotional intelligence I clearly, obviously, still lack. We separated in February, and he's now off building a life I know nothing about.
我总是在抵抗内心讨厌一切、玩世不恭、想要独处的本能。我不喜欢圣诞节，因为它需要太多的诚意和情商，而这显然是我依然欠缺的。我们在二月分开了，他现在过着我一无所知的生活。
I was worried about how he'd do, alone at Christmas. But you know who is alone, in actuality? Me, the Christmas hater. I'm Grinch at the top of the mountain, looking down at the denizens of Whoville, asking in the smallest voice possible, do they miss me down there?
我曾担心圣诞节他一个人会怎样。但你知道实际上谁才是一个人吗？是我，这个圣诞仇恨者。我是站在山顶上往下看呼呼镇（Whoville）居民的格林奇，用极小的声音问道：他们想我吗？
Because though I was always loathe to admit it, I did like so many things about Christmas with his family. I did like how I always felt warm and soft between December 23 and 26, like I was a big, fat baby in a plush blanket. I became comfortable with it. And eventually, I learned to look forward to it.
因为尽管我一直不愿承认，但我确实喜欢和他家人一起过圣诞节的许多方面。我喜欢在 12 月 23 日到 26 日之间那种温暖柔软的感觉，就像我是个被裹在毛绒毯子里的胖娃娃。我习惯了它，最终我开始期待它。
Christmas with him and his people was the closest to cortisol zero I've ever gotten in my life. My ex-husband's mother and stepmother always told me they loved me on Christmas Day when we exchanged gifts. And I always said it back. I meant it, too-- a rarity for me.
和他及他家人一起度过的圣诞节，是我一生中皮质醇水平最低的时候。前夫的妈妈和继母总在圣诞节交换礼物时告诉我她们爱我。我也总是回敬。我是真心的——这对我是种稀罕事。
I liked being a daughter-in-law and offering to help with the turkey, even though I have no idea how to cook a turkey. There was comfort in opening the garage door and seeing his cousins piled in there, wearing old Labatt sweaters, chain-smoking, and fighting over who stole whose lighter-- all these 40-something-year-olds reverting to who they were when they were 17. My ex grew up somewhere without the pollution of a big city, so you could always see the stars. I wish I had spent more time looking at them.
我喜欢作为儿媳妇去帮忙做火鸡，尽管我根本不知道怎么烤火鸡。车库门打开，看到他的堂兄弟们穿着旧毛衣、抽着烟、争论谁偷了谁的打火机——这种感觉很舒适，看着这些 40 多岁的人回归到 17 岁时的样子。我的前任在没有大城市污染的地方长大，所以总能看到星星。我真希望我当时花了更多时间去看它们。
To marry into a family that loves Christmas is to be conscripted into something that feels pleasingly conspiratorial. You know exactly what you need to do, and where, and for whom. The days pass and inch you closer to December 24, and you have a precise awareness of what's expected of and for you.
嫁给一个热爱圣诞节的家庭，意味着被征召进某种令人愉悦的共谋中。你知道你需要做什么、在哪里做、为谁做。日子一天天过去，离 12 月 24 日越来越近，你清楚地知道对你有什么期望。
And when the holiday is done, you have all these little secrets to whisper to each other in delight. "Remember that year my mom put brown sugar in the eggs she made for Christmas Day brunch?" my husband would whisper into my mouth while we lay in bed, after we returned to our lives in New York, to the albatross that increasingly was our marriage.
而当节日结束时，你们有一些小秘密可以窃窃私语：“还记得我妈在圣诞早午餐做的鸡蛋里加了红糖那年吗？”我丈夫会在我们回到纽约、躺在床上后，对着我的嘴唇低语，那时我们的婚姻已经成了越来越重的负担。
I'd laugh and say, "Yes, but we ate it. Because we love her, and we love each other, right? We love each other. Say it one more time, just so I'm sure that you're sure."
我会大笑说：“是啊，但我们吃掉了。因为我们爱她，我们也爱彼此，对吧？我们爱彼此。再说一遍，让我确定你确定。”
Now, all I feel is this constant twinge in my gut. It's like having a tail cut off. I wasn't supposed to even have one. But I did for a while. And now, I don't.
现在，我感觉到胃里有一种持续的抽搐。就像被砍掉了尾巴。我本来不该有那条尾巴的，但我曾拥有过一段时间。而现在，我没有了。
I thought about spending Christmas alone this year. I could do something devastating and romantic, like take myself on a solo vacation, maybe somewhere sunny, where I'd swan around in drapey fabric and look sad and hot and sad. Maybe at a resort.
我曾想今年圣诞节独自一人。我可以做些毁灭性但浪漫的事，比如独自去度假，也许去个阳光充足的地方，穿着垂坠的布料四处漫步，看起来既忧郁又性感。也许在度假村里。
Everyone there would think I had a secret. But the secret is, I'm sad. Instead, on both hands, I count the people I won't speak to this December. His folks, his siblings, his nieces and nephews, the cousin of his that was my favorite, the other cousin of his who always spent too much time touching my lower back, his aunt, who always called me Sasha, even 10 years in.
每个人都会以为我有什么秘密。但秘密是，我很难过。相反，我数着这个十二月我不会交谈的人：他的父母、他的兄弟姐妹、他的侄甥辈，我最喜欢的那位堂兄弟，那个总是喜欢触碰我后腰的堂兄弟，还有总是叫我“萨莎”的姑妈，即便认识十年了还是这样。
I'll add this pain to the several others that hardened me from the inside-out. The first year of divorce is just a march of agonies. Every notable event-- the first one you do by yourself. First birthday where we don't even speak, first family medical crisis where we don't cling to each other like driftwood in a tsunami, and now, our first Christmas apart.
我将把这份痛苦加到其他让我内心变硬的经历中。离婚的第一年简直是一场痛苦的行军。每一个重要的事件——都是你第一次独自面对。第一个我们甚至不说话的生日，第一个我们不会像海啸中的浮木一样紧紧相拥的家庭医疗危机，现在，我们分开后的第一个圣诞节。
My grief around my divorce remains wildly unpredictable. I don't have any strategy or plan on how to cope with the holidays. I just have to walk through a TJ Maxx and glare at the Christmas display and how I have no use for a Santa Claus cookie jar. I never did, but now, I really don't.
我对离婚的悲伤依旧完全无法预测。对于如何度过假期，我没有任何策略或计划。我只需要走进 TJ Maxx，怒视着那些圣诞陈列品，感叹我为什么需要一个圣诞老人的饼干罐。我以前从来不需要，但现在，我绝对不需要。
In the end, I decided to just go home this year and lick my wounds amongst my own family. My 12-year-old niece and sister-in-law celebrate Christmas with glee. There are cookies to be iced, and an embarrassment of riches under the tree, and a fireplace, and a mini dachshund named Beans, who will gladly snap a hunk of turkey off of your fork.
最后，我决定今年回家，在自己的家庭中舔舐伤口。我 12 岁的侄女和嫂子欢天喜地地庆祝圣诞节。有饼干要抹糖霜，树下有数不尽的礼物，有壁炉，还有一只叫“豆子”（Beans）的迷你腊肠犬，它会乐意从你的叉子上抢走一块火鸡。
Even my dad enjoys Christmas, if forced. He will never say no to a slice of pecan pie after a dinner that he complains does not have enough masala. I could conceivably find pleasure in this holiday again if I worked at it. But I don't want to right now.
连我爸如果被强迫的话，也会享受圣诞节。他在抱怨晚餐里的马萨拉（香料）不够多之后，永远不会拒绝一片碧根果派。如果我愿意努力，我本可以在这个节日里再次找到快乐。但我现在不想。
It's not that I like or dislike the holiday. It's simply that now it hurts my feelings. I crave nothing more than indifference, to view Christmas as but another holiday that isn't mine-- Easter, Hanukkah, Eid. You won't see me crying over Casimir Pulaski Day.
并不是我喜欢或不喜欢这个节日，只是现在它触动了我的伤心事。我只想感到漠不关心，把圣诞节看作另一个不属于我的节日——复活节、光明节、开斋节。你不会看到我为卡齐米日·普瓦斯基日哭泣。
For the last year, everything has felt either triumphant or devastating. And it would be nice to feel, instead, nothing at all.
过去一年里，一切都感觉要么是凯旋，要么是毁灭。如果能感觉什么都没有，那该多好。
Scaachi Cole is the author of One Day We'll All Be Dead and None of This Will Matter, and a cultural reporter at BuzzFeed News. Her story was produced by Diane Wu.
斯卡奇·考尔是《总有一天我们都会死，而这一切都不重要》的作者，也是 BuzzFeed News 的文化记者。她的故事由黛安·吴（Diane Wu）制作。
Our program was produced today with holiday spirit by Sean Cole. The people who put together today's program include Jane Ackermann, Bim Adewunmi, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Cassie Howley, Valerie Kipnis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu.
今天的节目由肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）带着节日精神制作。参与今天节目的团队成员包括简·阿克曼、比姆·阿德武米、米哈尔·科米特、阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德、卡西·豪利、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅利、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, and our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Larry Weissman, a.k.a. DJ PreSkool, Rachael Albert, Ben Levine, Phoenix Henkle, and Majestic Retail in Redlands, California, where we recorded Santa Allen.
我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼，高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑是埃曼努埃尔·贝里。特别感谢今天的拉里·韦斯曼（又名 DJ PreSkool）、瑞秋·阿尔伯特、本·莱文、菲尼克斯·亨克尔，以及加利福尼亚州雷德兰兹的 Majestic Retail，我们在那里录制了圣诞老人艾伦的素材。
Our website-- thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive. That's over 750 episodes for absolutely free. Also, there's videos. There's lists of favorite episodes. There's tons of other stuff there. Again, thisamericanlife.org.
我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org，你可以在那里收听我们的存档，有超过 750 期节目完全免费。此外还有视频、热门剧集列表以及其他海量内容。再次提醒，thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, The Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he came into my office this week and spent, like, I don't know, 25 minutes working on the settings on my web browser. I really had no idea what he was doing.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给各公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，这周他来到我办公室，花了大概 25 分钟捣鼓我网页浏览器的设置。我真的完全不知道他在做什么。
Finally, he turns to me, triumphant, and declares--
最后，他充满胜利感地转向我，宣布——
The cookies are gone!
饼干没了！
I'm Ira Glass. Merry Christmas. Happy holiday. Back next week with more stories on This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。圣诞快乐。祝你节日快乐。下周《美国生活》将带来更多故事，再见。